prolonge la faire grégory qui a bifurqué
depuis quelques jours vers une affaire
la roche à la suite d'une indiscrétion
d'une erreur du juge simon marie-ange
laroche la veuve de bernard sera entendu
cet après midi devant la chambre
d'accusation
à la suite d'une première plainte
qu'elle a déposée qu'elle avait déposé
contre ce juge pour violation du secret
professionnel
il y a quelques jours elle déposait une
seconde plainte pour le même motif
dominique verdeilhan vous restitue dans
quel contexte marie-ange laroche va être
auditionné puis vous l'entendrez elle
même la sphère grégory devenue la sphère
simon vivra aujourd'hui un nouvel
épisode marie-ange laroche et muriel
bolle ont l'an dernier porté plainte
pour violation du secret de
l'instruction contre le magistrat
aujourd'hui après la parution de
l'interview dans nouveau détective les
deux femmes demandent que le juge simon
soit dessaisi du dossier
s'il ne dément pas la teneur de ses
propos restez de vilma innocente ou
coupable je n'en sais rien je ne peux
pas accuser quelqu'un ou dire que c'est
pareil je ne sais pas mais ce calcul je
sais que ce n'est pas bernard non plus
bon il lui manqua un pas comédie pour
savoir si c'est lui l'assassin
alors que les avocats de la partie
civile puis de les grands parents de
grégory 10
il n'y a rien contre la roche le
procureur général andy de même il n'y a
rien contre vers leur larousse est
aujourd'hui se permet de avoir donc de
crier que berlin aurait enlevé enfants
pour moi c'est plus poussif les plus
confiants sur la piste laroche relancer
aussi par le témoignage accablant de sa
belle-soeur muriel qui pour marie-ange
laroche aujourd'hui maintient la vérité
quand je sais comment ça s'est passé
dans ces auditions procès verbal si on
veut aller par là par la gendarmerie
moi même j'y suis passé je n'y crois pas
non plus
je sais ce qu'on est capable de vouloir
nous faire dire est ce qu'on voudrait
nous faire faire il y a eu dans cette
affaire des dérapages qui ont entraîné
des résultats catastrophiques on bernard
laroche est mort à la suite de problèmes
de ce genre et hong kong nous constatons
à l'heure actuelle que cela recommence
et nous pensons qu'il y à véritablement
autant j'ai extrêmement grave pour nos
clients si nous laissons continuer
l'instruction dans les conditions dans
lesquelles se déroule à l'heure actuelle
le jeu si on dément formellement avoir
livré les informations sur le fond la
faire le juge simon aujourd'hui se tait
il y à une plainte contre moi dit il je
répondrais devant le juge kim
interrogera